small boats carried nearly 46 000
migrants and refugees to British Shores
last year this group made it but dozens
died in their attempt the number of
people crossing the English Channel has
increased by 60 percent detention
centers are overflowing and there's a
backlog of 160 000 people waiting for a
decision on their Asylum applications
government has announced a new policy to
deal with the issue we are introducing
legislation to make clear that if you
come here illegally you can't claim
Asylum you can't benefit from our modern
slavery protections you can't make
spurious human rights claims and you
can't stay
we will detain those who come here
illegally and then remove them in weeks
either to their own country if it is
safe to do so
or to a safe Third Country like Rwanda
but the migrants and refugees in France
waiting to make the crossing insist
nothing will deter them I'm prepared I'm
here for I'm I'm ready like to lose my
my life you know beside the going to
England yeah
Charities who work with refugees warn
stopping small boats like these will
deny legitimate Asylum Seekers the
protection they need it's going to lead
to potentially tens of thousands of
people being detained across the country
for a period of time we don't know
um and it will you know push people into
destitution and misery and it won't have
any impact on the numbers of people who
are forced to take dangerous Journeys
across the channel each year
instead they want the government to
invest more in the so-called safe
passage routes for refugees to reach the
UK at the moment it's only available for
those fleeing Ukraine Hong Kong and
Afghanistan there are only 22 Afghans
use this path last year while eight
thousand six hundred arrived by small
boat
000 refugees and migrants are expected
to cross this Channel and score boats in
the next 10 months according to the home
office whether this proposed policy will
deter them or even encourage a fresh
wave remains to be seen but what's clear
is that legal and practical challenges
of this new legislation will be enormous
Charlie Angela Al Jazeera South Sea